[Music]
all right tonight we start with proofs
the deep state is real in America and
that you the American people see what is
really going on pay attention to this
poll according to a brand new Monmouth
poll 74% of you the American people say
you think this group of unelected
bureaucrats are secretly trying to
manipulate policy and it's deeper than
that we're going to have a ton of
examples that prove that you are in fact
right but we'll start with the
predictable fake news attack from
liberals and the destroyed Trump media
they're trying to claim that former that
President Trump fired former FBI
director Andrew McCabe okay number one
they're not only idiots but guess what
they actually may even believe their own
lies President Trump did not fire former
Deputy Director of the FBI Andrew McCabe
the FBI fired Andrew McCabe based on
their investigation and of course
information from the inspector general's
report that we know will be forthcoming
all you have to do is look at the
Attorney General jeff Sessions statement
which apparently the liberal media
that's so overpaid and lazy did not do
now sessions explains that after a very
extensive investigation that the DOJ
Inspector General provided its report to
the FBI's office of Professional
Responsibility and then quote the FBI's
OPR then reviewed the report and
underlying documents and issued a
disciplinary proposal recommending the
dismissal of Andrew McCabe
now both the OIG the FBI OPR their
reports concluded that McCabe had an
unauthorized disclosure to the liberal
news media and that pay attention he
lacked candor including candor under
oath on multiple occasions that's called
lying to the FBI so the FBI and the DOJ
Inspector General determined McCabe lied
on multiple occasions that in and of
itself can be a crime now McCabe can
only blame himself and by the way what
cannot be understated is how significant
this move is for the FBI and the DOJ to
recommend that McCabe be fired it means
he did something radical
wrong at the FBI in fact sources are
telling us tonight
again that McCabe in the future could be
facing multiple charges it's that
serious I know the media is not telling
you that now I'm a cave deserve to be
shown the door and we're also learning
tonight that just like James Comey omma
cave kept memos of his interactions with
President Trump and McCabe's memos they
just reek of desperation this is like
remember Susan Rice James Comey they all
kept memos in Rice's case two weeks
after a meeting at the White House with
Obama Comey others rice she emails
herself just minutes after Donald Trump
becomes a president Oh Obama says do
everything by the book President Obama
says do everything by the book the only
reason rice was doing that that was a CI
cya now President Trump reacted to all
of this news about McCabe blasting the
corrupt media's coverage he wrote on
Twitter the fake news is beside
themselves that McCabe was caught called
out and McCabe was fired how many
hundreds of thousands of dollars were
given to McCabe's wife in its campaign
by crooked Hillary Fran Terry McAuliffe
who also is under investigation how many
lies how many leaks and Comey knew it
all and much more the president's a
hundred percent right if the media had
their way mccabe and accused liar and
potential law breaker would still have
the number two job at the FBI most FBI
people I know don't want him to have
that job now the media does not care
about the facts like McCabe's wife Jill
she got over seven hundred thousand
dollars an obscene amount of campaign
money from Clinton BFF Terry McAuliffe
and another Democratic group for a
failed Virginia State Senate run now
mccabe eventually ended up recusing
himself from the Clinton email
investigation because of all of this but
only one week before the election in
2016 then there's the fact according to
The Wall Street Journal McCabe waited a
month to notify Congress that thousands
of uma Aberdeen's emails were found on
Anthony Weiner's laptop now McCabe he is
totally a shady deep state actor
mccabe got caught red-handed and it
looks like mccabe is still going to end
up getting some of his pension in spite
of reports to the contrary and the left
in this country they are rushing to
offer democrats rushing to offer mccabe
all sorts of various jobs the reason for
mccabe being fired is so obvious that
even leading Trump hater himself soon to
be MSNBC conspiracy theorist congressman
Adam Schiff Liz Schiff is kind of
admitting that we're right take a look
on Andrew McCabe does the fact that the
Inspector General did say did find that
he lacked candor in some of his
responses and that his firing was
recommended by career FBI officials does
that give you pause and doesn't suggest
that in fact his firing was or maybe
justified you know his firing may be
justified there's no way for us to know
at this point but even though it may
have been justified it can also be
tainted my bet is he knows it's
justified look every once in a while
even shiftless Schiff you know he kind
of malfunctions and slips out of his
destroyed Trump default setting and
actually tells the truth this is one of
those rare instances now other members
of this deep say state Warren is so so
accepting of reality former Obama CIA
director remember he's supposed to work
for you the American people now he's
caught up in several of the scandals but
he's out there tweeting as arrogantly as
James Comey well the full extent of your
venality moral turpitude and political
corruption becomes known you will take
your rightful place talking about Donald
Trump as a disgraced demagogue in the
dustbin of history you may scapegoat
Andy McCabe but you will not destroy
America America will triumph over you
really this coming from Brennan this guy
who once voted for the Communist Party
that candidate for the communist party
running for president mr. president by
the way I look forward to learning about
what you knew and when you knew it on a
variety of issues and I have a funny
feeling we will be hearing a lot more
about you in the future you were
supposed to mr. Brennan served the
American people not your selfish deep
state agenda and as for Andrew McCabe
after being fired he issued a statement
that is creating what is nothing short
of a legal nightmare
for his BFF his buddy james comey now
mccabe writes in part quote the OIG
investigation has focused on information
I chose to share with the reporter
through my public affairs officer and a
legal counselor as deputy director I was
one of only a few people who had the
authority to do that it was not a secret
it took place over several days and
others including the director ding-ding
that would be Comey were aware of the
interactions with this reporter it was
the type of exchange with the media that
the deputy director oversees several
times per week in fact it was the same
type of work that I continued to do
under director Ray at his request
so mccabe is actually admitting that
Comey knew that he was engaging in a
media leak which is the reason why he
got fired or part of the reason on top
of lying under oath now it sounds like
McCabe either slipped up or is throwing
his best friend James Comey under the
bus because back in 2007 2017 in May
Comey gave a very different answer about
leaks to Congress while James Comey was
under oath so who's right James Comey or
mccabe saying this let's take a look at
the videotape director Comey have you
ever been an anonymous source in those
reports about matters relating to the
Trump investigation or the Clinton
investigation never questioned to one
relatively related have you ever otter
eyes someone else at the FBI to be an
anonymous source in news reports about
the Trump investigation or the Clinton
investigation no no okay with evidence
like that coming out you would think
that Comey wanted to keep his big mouth
shut but that's not what he's doing
instead you got Comey he's out there on
Twitter he's taunting the president
ahead of his big liberal media book tour
blitz tweeting out quote mr. president
the American people will hear my story
very soon and they can judge for
themselves who was honorable and who was
not James like
been saying mr. Comey you have the right
to remain silent I don't know who your
attorney has got to help this guy but
since you're interested in auditioning
to become the next liberal media darling
by going on the view and going on with
Colbert and sitting down with Clinton
sycophant Georgie Stephanopoulos we have
some questions for you mr. Comey well
you're more than welcome to come on this
show share what you claim is your
inspiring story I'll give you the entire
hour right here on this set I'll give
you three hours on my nationally
syndicated radio show I'm on five
hundred and seventy five stations come
on four solid hours you want to get the
truth out you want to be our guest you
want to answer a few questions come on
you're welcome
for example what did you know about
Andrew McCabe's leaks and Andrew
McCabe's lying under oath you know why
did you tell President Trump that
Clinton that bought and paid for dossier
with Russian lies why did you say it was
salacious and unverified in January 2017
at a meeting with at Trump Tower but
three months earlier in October 2016 you
were using that same dossier to get a
warrant to spy on Carter page and that
was the bulk of the FISA application so
mr. Comey come on the show and tell us
why the FBI also never corroborated or
verified the dossier and did you know it
used current and former Russian
government sources which is supposed to
be a big deal did the FBI make any
attempt did you make any attempt to look
at Christopher Steele's Russian sources
and interview them yourself did anyone
at the FBI asked Steele about his
sources did you pay Christopher Steele
there are reports that you did pay them
and what about fusion GPS did you ever
ask lend Simpson or anyone that the
company if they ever tried to verify the
dossier because the answer's no they
didn't and by the way then there's the
fires of court mr. Comey personally you
are aware of course that the FISA judges
did you not know that they were lied to
did you not know they were never told
that Hillary Clinton had bought and paid
for the unverified Russian propaganda
dossier were you at all aware in the
bulk of the FISA application
being made up of those Russian lies or
how about Andrew McCabe saying without
the dossier there would not have even
benefice a application did you know that
as well you're close friends with Andrew
you were his boss will you also aware
that Clinton paid her money through her
campaign for these Russian lies and
Clinton's campaign the DNC they funneled
over 12 million dollars through a law
firm
Perkins cuy did you know that - why did
they funnel that money and then there's
the fix Clinton email investigation mr.
Comey sit down and explain why any
investigator you work for the FBI
why were you writing an exoneration
months before interviewing not only
Hillary Clinton but 17 other key
witnesses that's what you did in Hillary
Clinton and the email investigation now
take a look mr. Comey at the side of
your screen you are probably familiar
with 18 USC 793 that makes it illegal in
other words against the law - mishandle
classified top secret special access
program information did Hillary Clinton
miss handle all that information by
keeping that unsecured server in the
bathroom of a mom and and pop shot pop
shop closet Oh was she trying to
circumvent congressional oversight now
you were really originally said it was
likely that hostile foreign actors
hacked into Hillary's server did Russia
hack into that server did China did a
Rand in North Korea did they gain access
to America's top secrets and Hillary's
emails oh what about the fact that
Hillary Clinton she deleted 33,000
subpoenaed emails mr. Comey is that a
crime is that obstructing justice we'd
like for you to explain a couple of
these reports take a look at these
headlines October 2016 FBI source
majority of staff on Clinton case wanted
her prosecuted exclusive FBI agents say
Comey it would be you stood in the way
of the Clinton email investigation mr.
Comey can you please explain those
headlines can we talk to the agents that
work for you that worked on that case
and what about what former FBI assistant
director James Kallstrom is saying to
the American people about all of this
you may want to pay attention I think we
have ample facts revealed to us during
this last year and a half that
high-ranking people throughout the
government not just the FBI high-ranking
people had a plot to not have Hillary
Clinton you know indicted so that she
could remain the flawed candidate that
she was which in my view was stupidity
and and they also had a and even this
struck I talked about this and they had
a back-up plan to basically frame Donald
Trump and that's what's been going on
this whole thing in my view is just
total phony I mean how would you feel
someone out there in americaland if
somebody was just had a phony scheme
about you and went on for months and
months and was so mr. Comey mr. deep
state here's an open invitation for you
to come on this show come tell your
story come sell your book and answer
some real questions and mr. Comey if you
care about the truth you know it's fine
go running to your liberal friends for a
little safe space to talk but answer
real questions here now also tonight
members of the fake news media they have
lost their minds yet again over all
things Donald Trump and in this case for
Donald Trump daring to call out the
extreme and abuse of bias the massive
conflicts of interest that's around
Robert Muller special counsel we've been
telling you this for a long time the
media just can't stand the fact that the
president is defending himself and
telling the truth no collusion and
exposing their agenda in their lies so
the president over the weekend he
tweeted out this has the House
Intelligence Committee has concluded no
collusion between Russia and the Trump
campaign as many are now finding out
however there was tremendous leaking
lying corruption at the highest levels
of the FBI the Justice Department in the
State Department
hashtag drain the swamp now Muller has
been at this for almost 10 months
Congress for over fourteen months and so
far nothing no evidence of Trump Russia
collusion Muller if you got it
come on the show and tell America and by
the way if the media if you have more
proof that this is not a witch-hunt okay
I don't believe you Axios is reporting
tonight the Robert Muller is more
interested in what happened after the
election than before the election
there's collusion supposedly was the
whole reason for the entire
investigation and by the way how can rod
Rosenstein this guy is so conflicted he
should have recused himself because on
the one hand he signs off on one of the
four FISA warrants using Clinton's
balton p4 Russian dossier and then he
also appoints Muller I say conflict of
interest now it's why the president
tweeted quote the Muller probe should
never have been started in that there
was no collusion and no crime it was
based on fraudulent activities and a
fake phony dossier paid for by crooked
Hillary and the DNC and improperly used
in a FISA Court for surveillance of my
campaign witch-hunt and by the way
people saying this weekend well act like
you're not guilty okay
saying I didn't do it means you're
acting like you're not guilty and then
the president added why does the Muller
team of 13 hardened Democrats some big
crooked Hillary supporters zero
Republicans another Democrat recently
added does anyone think this is fair and
yet there is no collusion the president
is right to be fed up with all of this
look at what it has done to this country
in the last year look at the side of
your screen
Muller's merry band of democratic donors
given over 50 grand to democrats
including Obama Clinton and the DNC none
of those people donated to the Trump
campaign so if the president's innocent
I say he has every right to be upset
every right to speak out Muller's swamp
and his thick deep state they are
abusively biased they've been shown to
be corrupt shown to have an agenda and
according to a report Andrew Weissman by
the way described by the New York Times
as Muller's pit bull attended Hillary
Clinton's election night party and
Janeen Rae did legal work for the
Clinton Foundation that's who's on
Muller's team and as for the media they
went absolutely nuts speculating that
was going to fire Muller no that's not
what the president said he said it never
should have started he never insinuated
in any way he was going to fire Muller
but that's not what you're lying news
media reported this weekend
president Trump sharpening his attacks
really taking aim directly for the first
time at Special Counsel Robert Muller
calling him out by name of course all of
that raised a lot of questions about
whether the president was trying to
undermine his credibility move to have
him fired the players in this
investigation covering this feel like
attacking this personally the way the
president has acted over the weekend is
a step toward firing Muller do you think
that the president is laying the
groundwork to fire Muller we've seen
this series of tweets right now the
statement from the Trump lawyer
suggesting the entire investigation
should be shut down what would happen if
the president made that move